ich möchte sie bitten sich von ihren
plätzen zu erheben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen verehrte
gäste die nachricht vom plötzlichen tod
philipp mißfelder hat uns tief getroffen
völlig unabsehbar wurde philipp
mißfelder aus einem kurzen leben
gerissen
das von früher jugend an ein leben mit
der politik war 1993 trat er als damals
14 jähriger in die junge union und 1995
in die cdu ein
er war von 1998 bis 2000
bundesvorsitzender der schüler union
seit dem jahr 2000 gehörte er auch dem
bundesvorstand der cdu an
im oktober 2002 wurde er zum
bundesvorsitzenden der jungen union
gewählt der bis 2014 blieb länger als
irgendeiner seiner vorgänger von 2008
bis 2014 gehörte er als bislang jüngstes
mitglied dem präsidium der cdu
deutschlands an
vor fast genau zehn jahren zog philipp
mißfelder erstmals in den deutschen
bundestag ein
er arbeitete zunächst im umweltausschuss
seinen wirtschaftsausschuss seit 2009 im
ausschuss für auswärtige angelegenheiten
mitte juni dieses jahres vor wenigen
wochen
gilt er als außenpolitischer sprecher
der cdu/csu-fraktion hier im plenum des
bundestages seine 121 reden
mit 35 jahren unter den jungen kollegen
war er links der erfahrenste es gibt
kaum jemanden in der geschichte des
bundestages der in so jungen jahren ohne
ein amt in der exekutive ein so dichtes
netz an politischen kontakten aufgebaut
hat im westen wie im osten
in den vereinigten staaten wie in
russland meine arbeit als
außenpolitischer sprecher der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion so hatte er selbst
auf seiner homepage geschrieben ist im
ziel gewidmet dass immer mehr menschen
ihr leben in freiheit demokratie
gleichheit rechtsstaatlichkeit und unter
wahrung der menschenrechte legen können
sein besonderes anliegen waren die
deutsch israelischen beziehungen
erzählte das zeigen die würdigungen des
israelischen premiers des botschafters
zu den engen freunden israels der jungen
generation eine stimme in der politik zu
geben war philipp mißfelder besonders
wichtig dieser einsatz schuh
freundschaftliche verbindungen über
parteigrenzen hinweg
und wenn ihn sein beachtlicher
politischer instinkt gelegentlich im
stich ließ hatte er eine erstaunliche
begabung neue brücken zu bauen
persönliches vertrauen zu stiften oder
wiederherzustellen
die scheu vor verantwortung ist eine
krankheit unserer zeit hat otto von
bismarck für die damalige zeit vermutet
philipp mißfelder hatte diese show nicht
weil er früh verantwortung übernahm
gelangt ihn früher als anderen in der
politik einfluss zu nehmen
nun ist für den mißfelder früher viel zu
früh gestorben der deutsche bundestag
verliert mit ihm einen engagierten und
respektierten parlamentarier viele von
uns auch ich persönlich einen guten
freund er wird uns fehlen
und wir werden ihm ein ehrendes andenken
bewahren
unsere gedanken sind bei seiner frau und
seinen beiden kleinen kindern
ihnen und allen angehörigen spreche ich
im namen des ganzen hauses
unsere anteilnahme aus
ich dagegen